This video is brought to you by surf shark, VPN
what's up guys, Michael and his exceedingly fancy library here,
regardless of how you've been feeling about the state of life under quarantine
or semi quarantine, chances are, we've all had one shared fear,
confusion, but among that confusion, there is one consistent refrain.
We just got to figure something out until there's a vaccine.
Once we get that sweet,
sweet attenuated inactivity or modified virus in our bodies,
nothing will stop me from tiny Nana at the olive garden.
But as much as I can't wait to carbo load unlimited lukewarm breadsticks with my
fellow pasta as family,
there is one thing this whole COVID crisis has revealed about how we think about
it. How we as a society, love to worship medicine.
Don't worry.
I'm not here to hate on all the medical advancements that saved millions lives,
but there is one thing that gets lost in the mix public health.
And while this term is come a cool new thing,
everyone gets to learn about during our playground and apocalypse.
I think there's a general sentiment that it's just the thing you do until
medicine catches up and to figure out why in general,
that's an awful perspective.
I want to talk about one of humanity's most little diseases to Burke.
Your losis welcome to the wisecrack edition on how to stop a plague.
But before we get into it,
I want to give a shout out to this week's sponsor surf shark VPN.
If you're anything like me, you online shop more often than you go to a store.
I mean, I can't remember the last time I went to a mall.
That means I usually am using my bank info on various sites.
It's just one reason why I find a VPN to be invaluable.
A VPN is a virtual private network, which means that once it's turned on,
it sends your data through an encrypted tunnel,
which protects you against malicious cyber attacks.
By shielding your information with surf short VPN,
you can feel safe using your computer phone game console or any other device to
make a purchase.
Surf shark goes above and beyond with their additional features like clean wet,
which blocks ads and malware that may pop up while browsing and blind search,
which protects your browser from serving you targeted ads or sponsored sites.
The best part is that if you use the link in the description right now,
you can get served shark VPN for 85% off its normal price.
Plus three extra months for free go to surf shark.deals/wisecrack,
or hit the link in the description,
protect yourself online and download serve shark VPN today.
Now for tuberculosis is one nasty disease.
Fettuccine Alfredo left out in the sun for 48 hours nasty.
It is thought to have leapt from Bovis cattle or bison approximately
17,000 years ago.
And it's time TB has killed as many as 2 billion people throughout history,
making it as evil as like 2.2 million jonestowns it's
airborne and can cause symptoms and its host anywhere from weeks to decades
after exposure. That's right,
this dip disease can hide in your body longer than the Simpsons has been on TV,
which is to say way too long,
late COVID-19 symptoms range from asymptomatic to Holy I'm dead
in serious cases.
The TB bacteria replicates within the lungs causing the Monia coughs night
sweats, chest pain and exhaustion.
It can also catalyze such a drastic loss of weight and strength that it appears
to consume the afflicted patient,
which is why it was eventually dubbed consumption after striking the world with
renewed fervor in the 18th century,
TB surged in Europe and America at the onset of the industrial revolution as a
story and Frank Snowden explains in his book, epidemics and society at the time,
it was known as the white plague because of the way it drained all the human
colors from your face.
The medical establishment understood basically nothing about the disease,
presuming it to be hereditary and because many famous artists contracted the
disease often writing or painting or composing great works while seriously ill
TB became.
And I'm not joking kind of cool disease itself was at degenerate
intoxicating effects and drove creativity.
Although as scholar Matthew Gandy notes,
widespread opiate addiction probably better explains this mental effervescence
for women.
The disease became associated with physical beauty and the amazing gated body
pale face flushed cheek look caused by TB became the height of fashion.
In some places, women would basically stop eating your exercise,
need to wear white face powder and blush to cosplay as consumptive that said
most victims of tuberculosis, weren't wealthy poets.
They were members of the urban poor, but we'll get to that.
But as germ theory spread throughout the scientific community in the late 18
hundreds,
tuberculosis stopped being a cool rich person disease and started being
something society wanted to declare war on.
It became viewed as a disease that punish the poor for their wretchedness.
Not only were people in overcrowded, slums, tenements, prisons, and alms houses,
more likely to become infected malnourishment and pre-existing diseases,
put them at a much higher risk for developing new life-threatening variety of
TB. In some countries,
a concurrent imperialistic urge to maintain a strong military made tuberculosis,
especially in crowded barracks and on the front lines,
a real existential danger.
This chain mindset helped give rise to what Snowden calls the war on
tuberculosis from approximately 1880 to 19,
which relied primarily on various public health interventions to present the
further spread of the disease.
Here's where it's helpful for us to quickly distinguish between medical
intervention and public health.
A medical intervention is basically everything you associate with going to the
doctor, getting a procedure done, being prescribed a medication, et cetera,
public health is everything outside of that interaction.
If getting a vaccine is a medical intervention,
public health is determining what vaccines people need,
attribute them to what new vaccines to research and educating people on the
benefits of immunization. And interestingly enough,
long before TV treatment actually worked TB rates plummeted starting in the mid
19th century in Europe and America because of a combination of intentional and
accidental public health measures.
One such strategy was the rise of the international sanitorium movement,
which advocated for isolating tuberculosis at what we're essentially fascist
club meds. They were first conceived by a German physician,
Herman Bremmer who experienced tuberculosis and healed in the Himalayas.
He credited his recovery to fresh air climate and rest.
And so started a sanatorium to standardize such treatment.
But the trend didn't really catch on until the 1880s with the establishment of
the first American sanatorium,
a little red near Saranac Lake in upstate New York,
where patients were required to spend eight to 10 hours a day outside,
soaking up the fresh air.
They also had to abstain almost entirely from exercise and eat a target of core
thousand calories a day to combat the consumptive effects of the disease.
Believing that negative emotions like shock or English stoked.
The illness nurses centered patients mailed to protect them from bad news.
These sorts of rules varied from institution to institution,
but across the board they made for a highly restricted life at the same time.
It also effectively quarantined those who were contagious,
which helped make a dent in the spread of the disease.
Getting into little red was a highly competitive process and many folks who are
rejected move to Lake Saranac anyway.
So the town became a sort of epicenter for TB treatment like Disney world for
the very ill while the medical intervention here is questionable.
This strategy had the inadvertent public health benefit of slowing further of TB
civically.
After spending time healing at the sanitorium patients would then return to
their urban homes. From there.
They would rely on dispensary's or medical centers that provided both medical
care and public health strategies like offering monetary loans or helping
patients find work. Importantly,
these dispensary's along with a slew of NGOs also offered community hygiene
education warning against the dangers of sneezing without covering your nose and
obsessing a little bit over the comparatively less risky act of spitting
concurrently starting around 1840 mid a little ethically questionable
was the segregation of the poor suffering from TB into work houses.
And it's widespread movements like this that really helped contain the disease
from further spread as scholar Matthew Gandy notes before the infectivity of the
disease was understood. British workhouses admitted,
ever greater numbers of consumptive patients.
Continuing the issue then is not the effectiveness of treatment,
but the impact of containment on rates of infection.
Another social campaign about the spread of cow TB led to the screening of herds
for the disease and the now ubiquitous practice of pasteurizing milk at the same
time, these public health efforts, intensified improvements in nutrition,
urban housing,
and the proliferation of more hospitals were concurrently fighting TB while
public health was kicking TVs. What new treatments were doctors concoct,
just a little thing called artificial neumothorax,
which basically collapsed and paralyzed the patient's lungs,
which they thought would allow them to heal like a broken bone in a cast.
Needless to say, this did not work.
A vaccine was debuted in 1921,
but it was mired in controversy because it a was not totally effective.
And B doesn't protect against all forms of TB.
By the time antibiotics for TB came around,
reported cases of TB had already plummeted Europe. Of course,
even on the public health front, there's a debate about what stopped TB.
According to some, including historian,
Thomas Macallan TB was stamped out by a cocktail of social and economic
interventions. He points especially to improvements in nutrition,
which strengthened people's immune systems,
thus making them less susceptible to its ravages.
Other scholars pushed back on this interpretation leading to a battle between
nutritionists or those who credit the decline of TB to better human resistance
against the disease via improved nutrition, water,
and overall standard of living and contagious,
or those who stressed the reduced sources of infection due to a variety of
public health interventions.
Contagion is believed that the declining TV was due to successfully identifying
and quarantining afflicted patients.
Vis-a-vis sanatoriums as well as broader public health campaigns with
dispensaries to NGOs regard of what you believe.
It's super important to note that it was some form of public health efforts and
not medical intervention that effectively combated this disease for decades
effecting change in everything from workplace safety regulations to improve
sanitation. Sometimes the public health part isn't even intention.
Robert Koch suggested that even housing design could influence how infectious
the disease could be. You might be asking, so what we've got drugs now,
housing design be damned.
And I'm only a few clinical trials away from getting my bread stick out.
After the antibiotic revolution began in the 1940s,
doctors believed the war on infectious disease to be one,
it was declared a dying field and med students were discouraged from studying
it.
But it's precisely because we declared victory so confidently that we're all,
let's start with something you might've heard of antibiotic resistance in 1950
33 Selman Wachsman developed streptomycin,
an antibiotic that when tested on a TB patient led to full recovery,
according to Snowden this monotherapy or treatment via one rock-solid drug
really seemed like a miracle cure. However, Dr.
Soon realized that the TB bacteria what's becoming resistant to the meds.
So folks who underwent treatment or becoming sick again, and what's more,
we're now immune to the only real treatment.
So doctors developed two new medications.
Isoniazid in 1952 and rapamycin in 1963 to
supplement it and began treating patients with all three things in large part to
these discoveries,
TB declined for decades up until the mid 1980s and everyone expected that the
disease would be eradicated by 2010. So we're in the clear, right? Not so fast.
You rascally optimist TB eventually became resistant to all three
medications. And that was about to really hit the proverbial fan.
Nowadays the research laboratory is the focus of public health rather than
social or economic efforts as an article in the American medical journal notes,
departments of public health shed, sanitation housing reform,
and even hospital care.
And now to Burchill losis is back in 1985,
TV cases stopped declining over the next two years.
Rates started rising in the U S and blossomed into a full on pandemic in Eastern
Europe, Southeast Asia and Subsaharan Africa by 1993,
the who declared tuberculosis,
a global emergency so much for eradication.
Remember how people living in poverty were particularly at risk for TB within
the U S those most likely to be afflicted where traditionally marginalized and
impoverished folks, such as those who are homeless or in prison, what's more,
the emergence of HIV created a brand new class of people who were more
susceptible to the bacteria.
One really illustrative example can be seen in New York city,
which served as an epicenter of an outbreak in the eighties.
The city had experienced a fiscal crisis in 1975 that led to severe budget cuts,
which caused the dismantling of health,
public safety and social service infrastructures,
and the deterioration of living conditions for vulnerable populations.
Most ruinously, the department of health, slashed, budgets,
shuttering district health centers, chest clinics, and the city's TB hospital.
As a result, when the crisis re-emerged existing hospitals were overwhelmed,
had fewer staff and fewer resources to track the treatment of those who were
sick here.
We see why a medical intervention antibiotics is not sufficient in and of itself
in stemming a disease.
You also need proper public health infrastructure to administer the treatment
track the patient's recovery and prevent further spread on a more global scale
Snowden also credits the disease re-emergence to the massive displacement caused
by refugees, fleeing war economic catastrophe, or environmental disasters,
citing refugee camps as a perfect incubator for spreading the illness or just
reactivating dormant cases in substance here in Africa,
the devastating proliferation of HIV made a huge population vulnerable.
While on Eastern Europe,
the fall of communism dismantled the medical infrastructure,
making it harder to seek treatment for TB to this day,
doctors and scientists face and often drug resistant disease in the absence of
adequate public health infrastructure appears to show no intention of letting up
in 2017,
the world health organization estimated that there were over a half a million
cases of multi-drug resistant TB. So as you can see,
the battle against tuberculosis has neither been simple nor entirely successful
in 2018, 10 million folks fell ill from TB.
And 1.5 million died. And importantly,
the history of tuberculosis shows to some extent why waiting for medical
treatments is a gamble. Don't get me wrong.
There's plenty of examples where a baseline public health measure like mass
vaccination can make us all chill out and not worry about getting polio.
But the reason TV is so interesting to us is that one,
we see a disease being greatly reduced at first,
without any substantial medical intervention. And two,
we see the disease resurging long after we discovered ineffective medical
treatment.
What this shows is how critical public health efforts absent a medical
intervention really are to stop the spread of a disease. And as we face down,
COVID 19 collectively holding our breaths,
that of vaccine will manifest before the next football season.
We might get a little too used to relying on medical advancement instead of good
public health infrastructure.
And I'm not just talking about state of calm or the importance of looking like a
bank robbery. I mean,
disease trackers who can stop a pandemic before it starts research into diseases
emerging in livestock and bats,
affordable distribution of vaccines and treatments. And so,
because if experts are warning us of anything it's that we can expect more novel
diseases, infecting humans from our animal friends,
and these might be way different or worse than COVID-19 a big thanks
to our amazing patrons for supporting the channel and our podcast hit that
subscribe button. And as always, thanks for watching later, guys.
[Inaudible].